even Travis Kelsey needs the NFL to
chill a little bit the swifties are
loving the NFL pushing all things Taylor
Swift but the football fans are over it
and Travis has finally spoken he said he
thinks it definitely brings more to the
atmosphere and it's fun when they show
who is at the games but it's gotten a
little out of hand I mean the NFL
changed all their social bios to be
about Taylor he said they're just trying
to have fun with it although they might
be having a little too much the
broadcast came to Taylor 17 times during
the Chiefs Jets game had two commercials
with Taylor in it three commercials with
Travis in it and women drove the game to
be the most watched Sunday football game
since the Super Bowl do you think Taylor
is benefiting football or do you think
enough is enough